first and ten in the closing minutes of
the fourth quarter
ain't never getting married yet so
yeah women are nothing but trouble
i get hello
georgia speaking did you run to the
phone do you feel stupid
who was it nobody
this little tiff between your mom and me
will blow over don't make a big deal of
it
i'm not i'm just saying i'm better
suited to the single life
how you picture that okay well you know
the buffet at golden corral where
there's all kinds of choices and you can
have as much as you want
yeah it'll be like that only with hot
girls
georgie i'll bet you a thousand dollars
you're married before you're 25.
you got a bet i feel like i'm stealing
your money
georgie married his first wife at 19.
he never paid my father
[Music]
what's for breakfast i don't know red
bull cereal
mom usually makes his eggs and toasts
and the occasional meat
well mom in here is she whoa somebody
woke up on the wrong side of the bed
and you had a choice cause you had the
whole bed gorgey
walking on thin ice maybe you should go
across the street and apologize
i can't do that why not cause if i do
what sets a bad precedent
what's nixon got to do with it what you
said bad president
like nixon you know this guy
you going to apologize
dad dad
if you are bring back me
oh sugar apple i love you so much
your affection for inanimate objects
frightens me
i'm glad you're happy missy i'm even
happier that i got a toy and sheldon got
nothing
well now we're not exactly done shopping
sheldon
you still want that computer i thought
we couldn't afford it
don't you worry about that do you want
it or not
more than anything all right then let's
go get it wait
he gets a computer and i get a lousy toy
i thought you liked it not anymore
okay water's definitely on it's right
now we want delicate or regular
it doesn't matter just turn on it's
going delicate to be safe
nothing damn it wait i know what to do
what
go across the street and apologize to
mom
i got nothing to apologize for you don't
have to mean it
i never do george you just mind your
business okay sorry
case you're wondering i didn't mean that
see how easy it is
what what no
[Music]
button you pull that's stupid